et ce soir c'est les trompettes de la
renommée
c'est beaucoup la wii c'est fou la c
triomphe absolu je vais vous dire c'est
ce nu c'est à dire mais ça rembourse de
plein de moments de solitude quand on
est juste avec un stylo voilà
alors pierre perret nombreux dernier cd
comme depuis quelques années vous
aborder des problèmes de sociétés assez
grave mais toujours avec votre langage
coloré et vous dénoncez dans ce disque
les déviances sexuelles
les sectes le dopage dans le sport la
guerre la pollution la drogue le racisme
les marchands d'armes et dangers du du
tabac vous pourrez pas que finalement
elle s'est un petit peu enfoncer des
portes ouvertes n'ont su sein d'autres
je ne suis pas le seul à parler de ça
antoine un bouton on écoute ça toute la
journée
bon je pense que c'est par un prisme un
peu particulier qui est le mien qui est
un homme une vision de la chose
je pense qu'il ait jamais superflu de
rappeler aux enfants que un dealer c'est
de la merde et dealer que c'est de la
merde un dealer c'est jamais inutile de
le dire même aux enfants et j'espère
qu'un jour ces chansons là seront
apprises dans les maternelles même celle
qui porte mon nom alors est-ce que c'est
pas difficile finalement de dénoncer les
malheurs du monde la misère du monde
quand on vit dans une maison de rêve
comme ça à nangis en seine-et-marne avec
vingt mille bouteilles de vin dans sa
cave est ce que détient pas un décalage
c'est la seule chose qui aimons bien ma
richesse
mon bonheur celui d'avoir une maison
accueillante pour y accueillir sur tous
les amis et puis bon j'ai pas de laverie
automatique j'ai pas de point de deux
restaurants sur les champs elysées à
faire de la bouffe rapide ça m'intéresse
pas ce genre de d'argent là
m'intéressent pas parfois
o2 et coléreuse et tout vole en éclats
et ça va
sachez que si kate
la gauche y
m
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya deux trois
ans on a vu revenir georges brassens
d'un seul coup les français se sont
rendus compte que brassens je parle des
jeunes évidemment sont rendus compte que
brassens était un chanteur de folk
français quoi et que c'était intéressant
et je représente est le suivant je
voyais l'autre jour un journal comme
libération qui vous rend hommage sur une
demi-page serait pas été le cas il ya
cinq ou dix ans je ne sais pas ce qui
leur arrive à tout aussi là
alors on va maintenant passer à la 2e
actu de pierre perret donc ça c'est un
dictionnaire et qui s'appelle le parler
des métiers et c'est édité chez robert
laffont
enfin
alors on se sent page 13 mille deux cent
dix entrées 145 profession alors ceni
sur l'argot ni sur les vieux métiers
c'est sur les métiers d'aujourd'hui ça
oui bien sûr tu aimes bien sûr c'est
tous les métiers d'aujourd'hui vers
lesquels j'ai envoyé des enquêteurs
principalement des linguistes qui savait
de quoi il parlait qui savait poser les
bonnes questions parce que c'est pas
toujours évident 1 et principalement des
femmes qui sont allées un peu dans tous
les coins de l'hexagone pour questionner
des gens qui mettait des sardines en
boîte qui faisait de la viticulture qui
était cordonnier qui était flic qui
étaient tous tous pour rapprocher de 150
p t il en faut beaucoup alors il se
retrouve même dans les commissariats ou
des églises ou des morgues questionnant
des gens pour obtenir parfois
d'élocution assez assez cocasse
hallucinante où curieuse c'est vous qui
les ai payées lors on pourrait penser
quand même que c'est le boulot de
l'académie française d'envoyer des gens
dans les provinces pour recueillir les
jargons c'est un travail qui aurait été
certainement dans leur domaine et
c'était plutôt à eux du recul ce
patrimoine comme moi parce que je ne
suis qu'une personne tout tel physique
est bon mais ça m'a fait un plaisir fou
de lui offrir ça parce que je me suis
offert ça alors en 63 moi j'avais 14 ans
quand votre premier succès le tord
boyaux est sorti et j'ai appris en
préparant cette interview qu'en fait
c'était pas complètement innocent parce
que vous êtes né dans un café restaurant
vos parents étaient bistrotiers et quand
on sait ça c'est explique assez bien
votre votre truculence votre humour
votre façon d'être
vos parents s'appelait maurice et
claudia perret et il avait le café du
pont à castelsarrasin la sortie de la
ville entre les usines d'aluminium et la
caserne et alors ça a été votre école de
la vie c'est le bistrot de vos parents
oui parce que autour d'un comptoir dans
un café les clients refont vraiment le
monde et puis votre mère qui
vous en voyez vous coucher qui vous
tirer par la manche ce soir il ya encore
les propos de nez un peu scabreux s'est
vu tu en as assez entendu rentrer se
coucher
la phrase c'était pierrot à la cuisine
il a 14 ans conservatoire de toulouse 15
ans conservatoire d'art dramatique 19
ans 1er prix de saxo et accessits de
comédie et puis débuts sur les planches
à vous commencez à vouloir jouer et là
il ya un libraire qui vous fait
découvrir la lecture qui vous passent
des classiques français c'est lui qui
vous a vraiment branché sur les mots oui
un monsieur merveilleux qui a comblé les
lacunes qui étaient les miennes
parce que partir après un certificat
d'études et se trouvait confrontée au
texte de molière shakespeare ou courtes
les eaux musset j'étais très malheureux
et même un peu humilié faut bien le dire
parce que c'est très très humiliant
quand on sait pas on entre dans un monde
dont on comprend pas tout
personnellement j'étais moins qu'une
sensibilité quand même
et un jour ce monsieur je suis rentré
pour acheter un
un bouquin au rabais je crois que je
jouais les plaideurs le petit jean des
plaideurs racines et j'ai demandé en
bouquins bon marché et c'est la hat
andry il m'a vu il m'a dit bombe venait
et il m'a amené dans une caverne d'ali
baba qui l'avait hors de la librairie à
100 mètres de là et c'était des
anciennes caves de 2 qui datait d de
deux trois ou quatre cents ans et il y
avait des trésors là dedans du bouquin
théâtre de poésie de tout mais des
bouquins très ancien et laissez vous
servir il m'a laissé me servir et il m'a
mis en main des ouvrages que j'aurais
jamais
lui tout seul vous monter à paris vous
êtes fan de brassens à l'époque et vous
allez voir dans sa loge vous vous lier
d'amitié avec avec brassens et c'est ça
sa compagne pub chaîne qui vous a dit
chante et d'une certaine façon ce
dossier pas le faire avant que j'y vis
mais je suis pas chanteur ali muzer non
plus alors vous êtes remarquer félicité
à l'époque donc par boris vian et
jacques canetti grand et grands hommes
s'il en fût canetti des joueurs de
talent hors pair et 10 barclays vous
signe un et là vous faites la
connaissance de simone mazal taryn qui
devient votre compagne après que vous
l'ayez rebaptisé rebecca quand même oui
c'est vrai simon et la ligue mince on
épouse toujours la même c'est fou car 40
ans 40 ans d'acharnement thérapeutique
mais si bonne c'est plus qu'une épouse
ainsi votre muse votte secrétaire votre
votre attaché de presse je ne fais rien
de d'importants je veux dire sans en
référer avec elle et l'oeil et l'oreille
les plus importants pour moi
pour sûr pour une chanson nouvelle c'est
c'est son oeil et son oreille si jamais
elle est là une réaction mitigée sur une
chanson je peux être malade pendant une
semaine sans le dire à personne mais je
vais je vais avoir les patates au fond
du filet pendant une semaine des as
c'est sûr